j'accueille maintenant roxana
maracineanu bonsoir d'être championne du
monde
ou vice championne olympique du 200
mètres d'où la première question
pourquoi nash sur le dos moi quand
genève sur le dos je me prend de l'eau
plein la gueule et je trouve ça très
désagréable parce que c'est la nage ou
j'étais la meilleure sa magie
on va vouloir manger
m
médaille d'argent pour roxana
maracineanu est doublé
cannes eu le temps ni dans le mixage
entre la base et à nu 2
des jeux de l'apic montant non
bravo médaille d'argent aux jeux
olympiques de sydney alors malgré ou à
cause de cette médaille d'argent
vous avez décidé de poursuivre votre
carrière jusqu'aux jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 sa matinée c'était mes
premiers jeux olympiques et puis j'ai vu
un peu ce que c'est et ça m'a vraiment
donné envie de revoir la flamme dans
quatre ans je vais gagner dans quatre
ans on verra on peut pas dire à la fin
de l'histoire mais c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je m'intéresse à la
nage sur le dos mais quand je vous vois
je comprends pourquoi le très joli en
plus ça change une bonne et des lunettes
mais bon on va pas tellement là oui on
voit jamais comme ça alors vous êtes
installé à paris là parce que vous allez
faire une école de commerce non voilà en
fait je suis parisienne depuis trois
semaines et j'ai repris mes études parce
que pendant deux ans je m'étais
consacrer vraiment la préparation des
jeux et là maintenant j'ai repris mes
études sur paris on va parler de votre
vie à vous aussi vous êtes né à bucarest
en roumanie en 75 vais commencer par le
patinage artistique
et puis vous avez trouvé que les profs
étaient un peu vis des méthodes un peu
spartiate
non surtout en gymnastique parce que
j'ai fait du patinage de la sonas tic et
puis c'est vrai que la roumanie c'est
vraiment un pays où la gym enfin on
attache beaucoup d'importance à ce sport
parce qu'ils ont une très bonne école
donc ils sont très durs aussi et
finalement comme j'avais pas tenu le
coup et c'est à ce moment là sur la gym
je me suis dirigé vers la natation et
finalement c'est là que j'ai eu la
meilleure chance en roumanie comment ça
se passait à l'époque seul lé talent été
repérés embrigader après ce que c'était
difficile parce que c'était comme en
allemagne de l'est où les champions elle
est championne était quand même traité
un peu comme c'est l'image qu'on s'en
fait ici mais c'était pas exactement ça
en fait
maintenant avec le recul je pense que
c'était une chance de faire comme ça
parce que au moins ont donné la chance à
plein de gens d'exploiter leurs talents
et
les professeurs de sport qui était dans
les écoles était en même temps des
éducateurs sportifs dans des clubs et
c'est de cette manière là qu'en fait les
jeunes étaient plus diriger après vers
le sport où ils étaient les plus doués
et c'est comme ça qu'après il pouvait
faire de la la compétition d'une ue à
votre père fin fin 80 début 90 3 votre
père se mêlent vasile qu'un géant
ingénieur de génie civil en bâtiment est
appelé pour reconstruire
l'algérie enfin se refait un bâtiment
algérien après le tremblement de terre
il part avec son épouse avec votre mère
elena votre frère stéphane
il est obligé de vous laisser ça c'était
bien les méthodes je m'adresse pas vous
puisque vous avez renier tout ça mais
c'était quand même drôle de méthode sûre
que vous on vous allez garder en
roumanie
c'est une sorte de tube chez ce coup
dont vous avez gardé en roumanie vous à
18 ans pour avoir un moyen de pression
sur votre famille c'est ça mais il
savait très bien que les gens à partir
du moment où il était à l'extérieur du
pays il allait plutôt avoir tendance à
aller à l'étranger puisque l'on n'avait
pas la liberté de la tendance à revenir
oui et
donc voila c'était un moyen en fait pour
que vous êtes restés là bas il a fallu
six mois de tractations avant vous
puissiez rejoindre votre famille et vous
retrouvez donc en algérie et au moment
de revenir en roumanie
votre père bas il est parvenu voilà
voilà il a pris la clé des champs n'est
rentré en voiture et on serre est énorme
dans le premier pays la faisait dire que
je vous torturent jean claude gayssot
mais à l'époque quand comment mais quand
des gens étaient prêts à quitter si on
laissait de la famille là-bas ils ont
pas laissé que c'est terrible cette
saison a laissé de doute jean mais quand
les gens étaient prêts à ça a tout
quitté son père hugues rentrer en
roumanie en vendant notre jury tel à
marseille tu le prêt à lyon via paris
c'est quand même fou mais ça vous voyez
bien à l'époque quand même genou on le
voyait en nous était pas communiste mais
on voyait bien que les gens étaient
prêts à tout pour quitter ses ces
régimes totalitaires
c'était pas le communisme la marche et
il allait bien passer ses vacances au
bord de la mer noire
j'ai dit aux chefs et le général de
gaulle qui à 68 était chez chaouch et ce
coup vous le savez il rendait visite à
un chef d'état
je marchais marché il allait en vacances
au bord de la mer noire
tout ce qui a été fait au nom du
communisme qui consistait à interdire
qui consistait à empêcher la liberté ou
qui interdisait à des gens de circuler
de se déplacer voire d'aller livre un
pays tout cela est condamnable mais pas
condamnable à 50% et condamnable à 100%
à boire je parle de l'époque moi je la
bats aujourd'hui tout le monde trouve ça
con grave ou le 1er mai mme robert hue
aussi euros vers lui était assis à votre
place et quelques mois il est exactement
la même chose y en a et b je voudrais je
parle du temps vous travaillez avec
georges marchais vous avez qu'est ce qui
vous a fait un tout ou rien et c'est
vrai que non mais franchement rien on
n'avait pas eu de chance de le croiser
vous adhérez riz non non taisez-vous
ardisson n'ont jamais ce que vous auriez
pu écrire un livre et vous aurez plus
fortunés maintenant bien alors roxana
donc votre famille comme j'aime le dire
lyon paris vous dormez alors chez bien
vous aimez pas qu'on vous parle de la
petite immigrée et qui arrive et tout
bronzé comme dormir votre famille dans
une voiture pendant pendant trois
semaines c'est jamais dormi dans une
voiture pendant trois semaines
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des difficultés au
départ ce que mes parents dû tout
quitter et puis laisser tout ce qu'ils
avaient comme comme moyens d'existence
en roumanie
et puis en arrivant ici il n'y avait pas
je veux dire on nous a pas tout donné du
jour au lendemain et puis tout ce qu'on
a eu la douleur on adule la famille
bonne famille qui est restée là bas il
ya eu des îles ont été menacés ils ont
été embêté suite à la défection de vos
parents il n'y a pas eu des choses aussi
terrible comme que ce que j'ai déjà pu
voir dans des films mais c'est vrai
qu'on les a en fait on a on a un peu
empêché leurs progrès social non là dans
la société et puis dans le voilà ce
qu'ils avaient un point noir sur leur
carte
quand vous êtes arrivé en france que
vous chose qui faisait le plus marqué
c'est les chewing gum avec leur
offensive vers l'est c'est fou parce que
vous dites vous dites que en roumanie
avait seulement le papier d'emballage or
on laisse antennes on les mangeait pas
et on apprend qu on les regarde et les
papiers dans des cahiers ou dans des
bouquins et quand on est arrivés en
france évidemment des chewing gum à la
chlorophylle y en avait c'est assez
touchant non ouais ça ne sais pas
comment ça a été perçu mais c'est vrai
que par exemple mon amant elle n'a pas
trop aimé que ce soit perçu comme ça
parce que ça fait un peu mais pour moi
en tant qu'enfant c'est vrai que ça m'a
fait très plaisir de voilà d'avoir des
bonbons des chewing gum des choses qu'on
n'avait pas là-bas forcément le côté
tricolore jean claude gayssot quand il
dîne avec renier votre temps des
qualifiés la victime dans votre famille
votre tombe par exemple elle dit que les
kin ancien prof d'université ya des gens
qui se veut dire sont restés dans la
mentalité de l'époque cirque elle trouve
que les gens qui gagnent de l'argent
c'est des voleurs par exemple vous savez
tout ça non qu'elle dit quoi l'argent
sont des valeurs dans ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya des gens dont vous
vous êtes venus ici vous êtes intégré
très bien on le voit
vous roulez plus les airs comme elvire
popesco ce qu'est vraiment génial ainsi
entraîner très bien ça se voit ça a bien
marché bravo mais il ya des gens qui
sont les irréductibles sur votre tante
elle considère que les gens qui viennent
de l'argent ce sont des voleurs il
n'avait pas l'habitude du commerce de du
profit individuel donc voilà il trouve
pas ça très très normal par rapport à ce
que ce qu'ils ont appris toute leur vie
m'a dit des choses aussi très belle que
d'autres gens ne disent pas donc qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans le régime
ici donc en france en europe occidentale
disant qu'est-ce qui manque par rapport
à ce que vous aviez en roumanie où l
éducation culture et cette manière de
faire qui qui fait qu'en fait tout les
gens toutes les personnes ou les mêmes
chances un peu dans la vie à partir de
ce moment là une fois que tout le monde
ait été éduqués que ce soit au fin fond
de la campagne dans la montagne dans la
ville et ça c'était un plus c'est un peu
comme nous quand on regarde les états
unis par rapport à la france
on trouve qu'ils sont un peu arriérés
sur plan social par rapport à nous donc
vous quand vous regardez la france
aujourd'hui vous pensez que par exemple
par rapport à l'éducation
il n'a pas les mêmes chances pour tout
le monde qu'il y avait dans les pays de
l'est il ya aussi la même chance parce
qu'évidemment on est nous aussi ici en
france on doit il ya l'école obligatoire
et tout ça mais là bas c'était un peu en
fait c'était l'école qui prime s et l
éducation qui primait sur la cellule
familiale
c'est à dire que toute l'éducation des
enfants étaient plutôt fait à l'école et
par l'école que les enfants étaient plus
pris en charge par le col que par que
par les parents ça vous choque pas la
france d'aujourd'hui qui est livré au
libéralisme le plus le plus sauvage ça
vous gêne pas vous pensez pas qu'on
reviendra un jour à des notions de plus
de partage et de solidarité
qu'aujourd'hui attention ça me choque
pas parce que je pense qu'on est sur une
bonne voie parce que les idées
communistes et
en fait c'est dans l'application
qu'elles n'ont pas marché mais dans
l'idéalisme elles sont très bonnes et je
pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens
et je pense pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens qui vont signé une question de
solidarité entre les gens et d'entraidé
puis penser à celui qui en face de vous
autant vous pensez à vous même je crois
que c'est une bonne chose mais d'abord
il faut d'abord mettre un système
économique viable en place parce que
c'est à dire que si chacun pense à son
intérêt et puis arrive à créer des
relations avec d autres gens autour de
lui mais on peut arriver un truc un peu
un peu jolie quoi la vdl et voilà les
magazines dits culma les romains non
j'ai tourné en roumanie l'année dernière
malheureusement pourquoi malheureusement
parce que ça s'est très mal face la
banque j'ai vécu au tournage le plus
désastreux de masi alors que j'entends
j'entends cette jeune fille par les
arguments de la roumanie parce que je
vais dire tu t'es là quand je disais
c'est terrible parce qu'on dit ça a été
terrible des années de communisme et
c'est encore terrible ce sera terrible
encore pendant 50 ans
en 87 vous reprenez en france la
natation 80 18 vous allez à perth en
australie
vous entendez donné championne du monde
qui s'est fait entendre la marseillaise
comme ça vous ça vous a pas pour moi
c'était vraiment le symbole de enfin
c'était ça voulait dire que j'avais
gagné
j'ai gagné les championnats du monde non
plus avant la compétition le président
de notre fédération nous a dit qu'on
n'avait jamais encore une champion du
monde ça donc voilà c'est là en fait
qu'on réalise un peu réagi violemment
contre la récupération qui est fait qui
a été fait de votre exploit quand même
nom quand chirac dit quel bel exemple
d'intégration ça vous énerve un peu vous
ita fait tout pour il y est pourquoi le
nom masqué ce qui m'a énervé c'est que
chacun pour voulait récupérer des choses
qui m'étaient très personnelle avant
dont personne ne s'était occupé ou
préoccupé même si ce n'est parce qu'ils
étaient déjà en place et puis après une
fois que c'était fait chacun on voulait
enfin chacun interprété ce qui était
arrivé aux intérêts mais bon mais il ya
eu des tentatives de récupération
politique on a bien vu donc à l'époque
chirac commercial aussi on vous a
proposé de faire un livre
vous a proposé de faire de la chanson on
vous a proposé du pub pour du shampoing
un film de sortir d'un gâteau
d'anniversaire vous souhaitez vous avez
résisté à tout ça mais c'était un peu
traître est différent pour moi parce que
la natation c'est pas du tout un sport
qui était médiatisée maintenant ça l'est
un peu plus et puis j'ai dû faire face à
des choses vraiment de nouvelles et
j'étais très surprise quoi part des
choses qu'on qui m'était proposé mais
après certaines choses parce qu'en fait
je les fais pendant quelques temps et je
me suis vite arrêté parce que j'ai eu
assez de gens autour de moi pour bien me
recadrer sur mes objectifs et puis je me
suis rappelé aussi que moi mon objectif
c'était pas ce titre de champion du
monde mais c'était une participation aux
jeux olympiques
et voilà donc j'ai mis deux ans je me
suis reconcentré j'ai oublié tout ça moi
alors s il ne s'est pas aux jeux
olympiques donc vous êtes médaille
d'argent avec cette une roumaine qui a
gagné c'est pas la marseillaise ce que
vous avez entendu c'est donc l'hymne
roumain mais c'est un peu magique c'est
vrai parce que c'est sur mes parents
étaient dans les gradins et pourquoi ça
leur a fait très plaisir
moi ça m'a fait un peu moins plaisir
parce que je me suis fait battre et puis
d'autant plus que c'était une roumaine
donc c'est pas disons c'est c'est pas
pour ça que ça être atténué la chose
puisque justement après j'ai reçu des
courriers on disait ben t'as une
médaille d'argent mais bon c'est une
roumaine ce bien oui mais c'est très
bien je suis très contente supporter
pour donner quatre maintenant quand vous
connaît mais moi j'aime pas trop me
faire battre donc voila merci